before you watch this video to make sure
you're not a robot please look at these
pictures and identify the street signs
the cars the fire hydrants the shop
fronts the numbers on the front doors
and the ever-growing sense of
frustration in the late 90s the most
popular search engine was Alta Vista and
they had a spam problem
people were writing automated scripts to
send in spam and malicious links to
their finely crafted database of the web
and they needed to add a test that only
humans could pass their solution was to
add a question to the submission form
that back then only a human could answer
and in their case it was to identify a
warped string of letters and numbers
image processing wasn't at the point
where a computer could easily identify
the squiggly characters but it was
trivial for a human or at least trivial
for a human with good eyesight
accessible versions didn't come along
for a while but that was one of the
first public versions of what became
known as a capture a completely
automated public Turing test to tell
computers and humans apart a version
called reCAPTCHA came along a few years
later it was used to help scan old books
and newspapers when a capture was needed
the team would send one scanned word
that they knew was right deliberately
distorted and another word that the
scanning systems weren't sure about the
user would have to type in both the
known word was to check it was a human
answering they had to get that right but
the unknown word after maybe a dozen
people had agreed on what it was that
would be logged as part of the books can
Google ended up buying recapture but by
then the arms race was well underway the
bot makers looked at recapture as a
challenge and they rose to it honorably
first they could train computers to read
those messed up words this was before
the recent breakthroughs in machine
learning and artificial intelligence but
even a fairly rudimentary system could
solve recapture well enough to let bots
makers create fake accounts and send
spam some of the time if the test was
still too difficult though they could
just pay humans the bot makers set up
systems where automated BOTS would fill
in all the details ready to send spam
and then when the capture appeared the
bots would show it to human operators
hired from countries where the average
income is low those humans got paid to
sit there and solve capture have to
capture after capture after all it's
only testing them as a human in the loop
somewhere you could even outsource your
capture solving needs to any one of
dozens of companies who all competed on
price and accuracy actually you still
can or you could get unsuspecting
members of the public to solve captures
for you you could set up a website with
some images that some people might want
to see and before they could visit they
would have to prove they were human by
solving a capture which was copied
straight from whatever site your BOTS
were trying to get into so then Google
released recapture version 2 which is
where you presented with a single check
box that you have to click on to prove
you are not a robot and clearly any BOTS
presented with that box would be honest
and not click it it's not really about
clicking the box when you complete one
of these new CAPTCHAs extra data is sent
and Google is very cagey about what that
data is because everything they reveal
is a clue for the people trying to break
it but that box is loaded into your
browser from google.com which means it
can look at any login cookies that
Google already have in your browser
certainly if you clear your cookies you
are way more likely to get that
secondary check that asks you to
identify buses or fire hydrants and
maybe it takes how many mouse moves in
the moments before click on the box in
the exact position and length of time
your finger tap the phone screen plus a
bunch of other things that Google all
feeds into their giant machine learning
system the only people that know for
sure are the designers and they aren't
telling the CAPTCHA solving services of
course are already offering a cost per
thousand to solve these in may be harder
but it's not unbreakable using machine
learning BOTS can be trained to pass
those secondary checks themselves and to
hide as humans
well identifying the correct sections of
the presented images is something that
you can throw cloud machine learning at
and given that Google cloud sells
machine learning systems it's very
likely that some of their servers are
creating captures and others are trying
to break them and even then you can just
have humans on standby instead so at the
end of 2019 Google released capture
version 3 and you may already have
passed or failed one of these without
knowing it no box to take no puzzles to
solve when you browse around a site
version 3 works in the background and
watches what you do by the time you post
your comment or signing up it's already
assigned you a score based on how likely
you are to be human and again Google is
being very careful about saying how
they're working that out with the answer
very likely it's a machine learning
system they're throwing everything into
and they don't know how it works either
hopefully they're taken account of
incognito mode and accessibility tools
because if you get a low score maybe
your comment will get sent to a
moderator to check or maybe it'll just
disappear into nothing and you'll never
know the bot makers of course are
already working on the challenge I
signed up for a new bank account online
a few months ago and I had to send in a
photo of my ID and a video of me holding
that ID and waving that's checking not
just that I'm a human but that I'm the
one specific human I claim to be BOTS
are becoming more and more
indistinguishable from human successful
capture methods having to be more and
more intrusive the arms race continues
as it has done for 20 years or more I'm
going to do something very strange for
sponsorship segments now I am going to
tell you about limits I've said you
should use a password manager and it's
true I use one I recommend you do too
which is why this video is sponsored by
dash line the password manager if you go
to - lang comm slash Tom Scott you can
get a free 30-day trial - Lang premium
and I recommend you try it out with
yourself but there are some things that
a password manager cannot help with if
you are worried that a major government
is trying to steal your secrets or
industrial spies with millions of
dollars of funding are targeting you
specifically well you probably already
have professional advice after all if
someone actually gets to your computer's
hardware and install stuff that pulls
things right out of the physical memory
well at some point even a password
manager has to decrypt the password put
it in memory and pass it on to wherever
you're actually trying to log into if an
attacker has physical access to the
hardware it's over
and of course the weak link in almost
every security system is human all the
security in the world cannot protect you
from someone threatening you with
violence unless you type in your
password and in the UK if the police
have a court order requiring you to give
them your password it is a criminal
offence to refuse people have been
jailed for it - Lane cannot help you
with that but using - Lang means that
every password is different so when some
online services signed up two years ago
and forgot about get
reached it's no big deal actually - line
will also warn you about data breaches
with instant alerts for websites where
you have accounts using - line also
means that every password is long
complicated and secure but you don't
have to try and type them in on your
phone because - Lane will autofill them
for you everywhere you go
it can even auto change passwords for
you on a lot of sites with the click of
a button
in short using something like - Lane
means that passwords stop being this
worrying pain in the ass and start being
something that it's really easy to deal
with I thought long and hard before
accepting sponsorship for this series
but honestly if you are tacky enough to
watch these videos you should use a
password manager so - Lane comm slash
Tom Scott for a free 30-day trial - Lane
premium and if you like it you can use
the code Tom Scott for 10% off a
purchase